okay gang step one we're gonna break in
em deactivate the weapon we look amazing
all right you get started on the
lockdown sequence I'm gonna hit the John
yes sir we gotta get that key card okay
Courtney get that card there's something
in the way Jack what's going on down
there
fire of the way hmm maybe it's on the
other side okay hold on pretend to be
[Music]
Oh No
Chuck get that card
[Music]
yeah I'm just gonna we're gonna need a
bigger slingshot Fred we've discovered a
third island we need to put aside our
differences and work together to save
the world from being destroyed we really
need actually that positions been filled
she's super smart who's that and why is
she all over these achievement award I
just don't think this is gonna work okay
so what and usually angry walk to
herself
left-handed probably with fun being
alone I need some muscle
look back there okay guys step one
travel undetected to the island all the
gadgets you see here have been designed
with your current mission in mind the
first Bing and visit spray how long does
the invisibility last for forever why
Tina we're not gonna be able to see each
other working with what we get
[Music]
oh it's on anyone smell bacon
[Music]